i thought they'd be good together
like pb and j
pam beasley and jim
okay this is officially the cutest thing
i've ever seen
cubbies
i totally forgot about cubbies there's a
finger painting station and a curly
slide
am i too old to go here
oh
adorable right
i walked in on someone in the bathroom
what i just walked in on some in the
bathroom who i don't know the i don't
know the guy we're meeting with i don't
know i don't know
there was one thing we were curious
about uh your flexibility on things like
easter or memorial day because we might
want to change our days around a little
bit that seems a bit premature don't you
think i don't even know if i have a
space for you yet and you're already
lining up your holiday plans oh no sorry
i'm just um
we're kind of planners
but we're also flexible too so you know
what maybe we could just discuss it when
the time comes yeah if the time comes we
can discuss it
is this because jim walked in on you
going to the bathroom
what
seriously you told her
did it i it might have come up while we
were waiting for you
and you you thought that might have
something to do with how the meeting is
going no maybe because it doesn't seem
to be going super well
you didn't consider the fact that it
might not be going super well just
because it it might not be going super
well
nope
cause we're really nice people but you
don't seem to like us
i'm being perfectly pleasant
did you ever consider that you might not
be as charming as you think you are oh
this coming from the guy who still uses
a children's toilet
why don't you just lock the door man
it doesn't lock for the children's
safety
anybody could have walked in
story time
hey everyone i'm here
i'm jake peralta the negotiator oh so
you're jake peralta the negotiator yes
who are you dennis cole esu this was my
crime scene before you bozos got here
nice to meet you too dennis i've spent
10 years as a negotiator and you just
took my first hostage situation all i've
done until now is talk jumpers off of
rooftops but that must be satisfying in
its own way right yeah really satisfying
saving a crazy person's life whatever
here's a little advice i don't like you
two not so much advice as it is a
hurtful statement based on limited
interaction he wants to talk to you
get the hell in there it says negotiator
on it
this is jake peralta
i am unarmed
and i'm approaching the building
you wanted to talk to me keep those
hands in here
i'll wave them like you just don't care
what
i'm just messing with you peralta put
your hands down give me a hug baby judy
we have three rooms each with a
different theme what are the themes
america irrigation and night time
irrigation
nice i'll put you down for irrigation
now then do you have any special needs
or dietary restrictions yes we will be
requiring a bedtime story
no
not even harry potter no jim come on but
you probably mo's bags now
here we are irrigation room very special
room
so i'll come get you before the table
making demonstration and as of this
morning we are completely wireless here
at schrute farms but as soon as i find
out where mo's hit all the wires we'll
get that power back on
alrighty
i'd say one in six what
oh i thought you asked me what our
chances were being murdered during the
night
you know i just realized
this is pam's and my first night away
together
i used to play it over my head
and it was just a little bit different
maybe a uh nice hotel or a romantic
dinner
wine
um but wine that wasn't made out of
beets
didn't think dwight would be involved at
all
and uh
i always imagine less manure you need to
spread it i mean some manure
just it's gonna work less this is beet
food moe's what are you doing nomos put
the put the manure down put it down do
not throw it do not ow
judy what's up peralta thank you so much
for coming look i thought about it and
i did you dirty i never meant to cause
you any troubles yeah well you caused me
a lot talking to a pre-recorded video
but it's cool i know what you're saying
i hear you in my heart what am i doing
here i feel the same way you're my best
friend too look i'm not coming back i
started a new life here in san diego
stupid telling me where you are come on
man i ain't no damn san diego everybody
knows that place subs here's what i want
to say though i'm sorry i won't be at
your wedding but i did record you a cd
of original shmush jams that will
consummate the marriage it's on the
table next to you along with a little
something else
a french gorilla crusade pot now look
inside it
the diamonds yes
i cannot believe you actually brought
the diamonds
yeah this time that one no you're the
best look even though i am a scorpion i
will never drown your adorable little
frog ass so that's what i had to say i'm
sure i'll see you again at some point
now that coupon you got there it's for a
full hour in the private room
so
[Music]
so
i said hey
oh what's going on
there yep thanks thank you
how much do you give him big tip wait i
don't have my scarf i'm missing my scarf
oh
we decided to have a valentine's day
lunch
and then that way we could spend the
entire night with cece and not avoid the
uh valentine's day dinner thing
it's a whole thing
yeah lunch was wonderful um there was an
amazing buffet and there was a chocolate
fondue station and what else was there
uh bottomless champagne yes
never found that bottom didn't we no
that's weird
i mean that's weird
to have sex in the office
that's where you work right
[Music]
you're in a meeting
and
nobody knows that you've had sex there
except for you and him
ew
ah hey hey hey no time to chat well we
were just looking for ryan so he's not
here hey you looking for me oh yeah we
were we were just looking to say hi so
hey
no you weren't
no we weren't you wanted to have sex in
my office nope definitely not that's wow
it's it's it's cool just um
try to put everything back where you
found it uh text me when you're finished
though i'll be out here hey you don't
have to
that was so embarrassing i'm gonna die
that was really rough
let me make something clear
jim and i have never and will never have
sex in the office
because the office isn't what i'd
consider a romantic place
besides we have something those other
people don't have which is a home and a
bed
not a shower
doug judy the pontiac bandit hey baby
nice legs
why are you in your boxes so you would
know i'm not wearing a wire
your buddy scott said i had to ah that
makes sense scott's a perv hey scott
wherever you watch it from go home sorry
man
that's what's so important i'm looking
for your foster brother george hate the
guy stole from my mom burned our house
down worst of all he ran off with my lp
of phil collins no jacket required it's
my favorite album i haven't heard in 20
years i mean
can't you just stream it can't do that
to phil cecilia demands vinyl right
vinyl and whatnot okay well george is a
murderer now and he just escaped from
prison we think he might be trying to
flee the country you want me to help you
catch him like when x-men teamed up with
magneto to stop apocalypse i heard that
one was bad it wasn't great i still want
to see it though i'll watch it again
does that mean you're in course i am
damn it feels good to be on the same
team for once cop and criminal working
together
need a theme song
the pontiac bandit and jager cops oh
taking down crooks in the streets where
they live flooding with girls who are
hopping a bath there's a talking police
dog that helps them solve crime
you